EDHRec is a fascinating tool that has grown
to monolithic stature, eclipsing most other
resources in the EDH ecosystem.
And this is not for no reason—a neatly organized,
ordered list of what cards other people play
is a useful tool.
Other people put thought and effort into crafting
decks, and you get a summary of that thought
and effort delivered directly to your eyes
via a snappy UI.
However, it’s not a perfect tool, due to
a variety of factors.
In the first Magic: the Gathering video I
posted to this channel, I made a point to
discuss some downsides of EDHRec that I hadn’t
seen mentioned before, and while it’s a
cool video that you should definitely go watch,
the contents of that video aren’t what I
want to talk about today.
Instead, I want to talk about a point brought
up in the comments to that video, that being
that displaying cards by percent inclusion
in decks flattens a lot of information about
the decks they’re played in.
If there are three cards each played in a
third of decks, it’s difficult to tell whether
they’re all played in the same third of
decks, if they’re all played in different
decks, or something in between.
And this is a flaw pretty inherent to the
construction of the website—it’s not some
emergent problem that popped up and is awaiting
a solution.
But it got me thinking—is there anything
that users of the website can do to adapt
to this fact?
When I look at a card on EDHRec, can I figure
out what it’s doing there, what other cards
go with it, and what all that says about the
decks it's played in, or even about the players
that built those decks?
The answer to this question is… complicated,
but as a process it’s taken me down a series
of rabbit holes as useful as they are bizarre,
and I want to share that journey with you
today.
As a fairly straightforward example, in late
December I was looking to make an aggressive
partner commanders deck, and I was intrigued
by the Commander pairing of Malcolm, Keen-Eyed
Navigator, and the freshly printed Francisco,
Fowl Marauder.
The appeal for me was strong—two low cost
partners, one of which ramps and the other
of which filters, which can be paired with
a further slate of low-cost pirates to enable
all sorts of shenanigans.
EDHRec had a mere 310 decks for this freshly-minted
pairing, so a question we can ask is “who
else jumped on these two as a worthwhile commander
pair?”
Looking at the 10 high synergy cards—the
ones disproportionately run in this commander
pair compared to the color as a whole—offers
a clear picture.
Almost 60% of Francisco-Malcolm decks run
Thassa’s Oracle and Demonic Consultation,
an instant win combo requiring a mere two
cards and three mana.
Looking further, we can see a bunch more high-powered
staples also at around 60% usage, but scroll
down a bit beyond that and we can see a very
different type of card at approximately 35%
usage—a couple of four mana pirates with
abilities useful in slower, more midrange-y
decks.
Ramirez and Hostage Taker are both fun cards,
but they’re decidedly not mana well spent
in a cEDH Thoracle deck.
For this reason, I’m going to call these
two cards, along with Thoracle, “indicator
cards”—cards that give you a rough idea
on the upper bound of players playing a particular
type of deck.
If I use the indicator cards of Thoracle and
Ramirez, I can start to construct a Venn diagram
with a combo circle containing 58% of decks,
and a midrange circle containing 36% of decks.
I wouldn’t expect a ton of overlap, and
indeed, a search with EDHRec’s filter feature
plus some quick math tells me that there’s
about 7% of decks that run both cards, and
about 13% of decks that run neither card.
Now what does this sort of analysis tell me?
Well my first takeaway from seeing the 58%
Thoracle play rate was, god damn, I guess
I’m on the right track if I’m looking
to make a high-powered deck.
To be clear, Thassa’s Oracle plus Demonic
Consultation will be run in some percentage
of any deck with blue and black in it, because
people will try to make high-powered versions
of any old commander, but 58% is a lot of
decks.
While it’s not a wincon I’d go for, the
fact that such a high percentage of people
building Francisco-Malcolm run Thoracle communicates
to me, somebody who’s building on a budget,
that I’m probably getting a lot of bang
for my 84 cents from the command zone.
For my part, I ended up including none of
the indicator cards I mentioned in the deck
I ended up building, because I’m a unique
and special boy.
For another example, about a year ago I was
building a Skeleton Ship deck.
It was intended to be a glacially slow proliferate
deck, and it had all the fixins’—the parallax
enchantments, some impressively slow wincons,
and the original storage lands that enter
tapped and don’t tap for non-stored mana.
The commander was a card that could be played
as a mediocre removal engine, but most games
it just sits there as a meme, a perfect encapsulation
of the slow mass of nothing I was doing.
So what decks do other Skeleton Ship players
build?
Looking at the high synergy cards, the top
5 are all cards that pair with Skeleton ship’s
ability, so already other people are deviating
from my gameplan by actually caring about
the commander.
Next up, in roughly 50% of decks are a bunch
of proliferate cards, which seems sensible
enough to me—that’s what I’m doing.
After that, in about 30% of decks, are a bunch
of skeletons, and in about 15% of decks are
a handful of questionable but undeniably skeleton-themed
cards.
Excellent.
Okay, so these are gonna be the three archetypes,
with our indicator cards for each being Freed
from the Real, Thrummingbird, and Reassembling
Skeleton.
We can now make a triple Venn diagram, and
fill it out by simply plugging in every combination
of these three cards in EDHRec’s filter
tool.
And upon doing this, the first thing I noticed
was that cares-about-commander-ability and
cares-about-counters seem almost like one
very diverse super-category, whereas Skeletons
were definitely more distinct.
If you’re a freak like me you’re probably
also wondering—what is that other 15%?
I did another filter excluding these indicator
cards plus an additional one from each category
to account for slight variances in card choice,
and the result is—pirates and cards with
ships on them.
Respect, honestly.
The Skeleton Ship page was fascinating for
the opposite reason as the Francisco-Malcolm
one.
This EDHRec page looks like something of a
tour of low-power EDH.
There’s the players who are earnestly building
around the Glorious card known as Skeleton
Ship, the players who took it as a jumping
off point for some strange quest into the
unknown, the people who are here for a commander
for their janky skeletons decks, and the people
who appreciate the card for all of its skeleton
and ship goodness.
I picked out Skeleton Ship as the commander
for my bad meme deck, and it looks like I’m
in good company with that fact, but the interesting
thing is how many different types of meme
are present here.
And honestly, the process of making this video
and returning to the glorious EDHRec page
has only increased my amount of love for all
my bone homies out there, living their best
Skeleton Ship lives.
For our third example, let’s talk about
Archelos, Lagoon Mystic.
This page has a lot more decks than the previous
two I mentioned, and yet somehow it’s honestly
the most confusing EDHRec page I’ve ever
been on.
High up on the page, we get some stuff that
makes sense—things that tap and untap the
commander, and lands-matter cards.
Sure, that makes sense, cards that lead to
lands entering tapped are good when the commander
has them come in untapped.
We also get Villainous Wealth—okay yeah,
I guess if you’re playing a lot of lands,
you may as well have an appropriately-colored
outlet.
And then you get down to stuff like King Macar,
the Gold-Cursed.
Are people playing him because Archelos has
him enter tapped and thus lets you get an
Inspire trigger a turn early?
Maybe, but there’s also a lot of tap/untap
synergies sprinkled throughout the page.
Not enough for me to get a confident idea
of what people are doing, but certainly a
handful, seemingly present in a hair over
20% of decks.
Next up is tribal turtle decks, and for this
we can see a bunch of turtles played in roughly
15% of decks, with about half that many decks
also running a bunch of questionable turtle-themed
cards.
We’ll call these turtle players, and dedicated
turtle players.
Finally, let’s talk gates.
The indicator cards I’m going to use here
are Baldur’s Gate, Nine-Fingers Keene, and
Maze’s End, cards played in a decent portion
of decks that you’d probably only want in
a gates deck.
Now, these play-rates confuse me a little
because, in my opinion as a professional gates
enjoyer, Baldur’s Gate is a much worse card
than these other two.
For early-game purposes it’s a wastes in
a three color deck, and the limitation to
three colors means that even if you run every
single in-color gate, only a third of your
lands will be gates.
I don’t love Keene either—its triggers
will whiff more than a quarter of the time
in a three color deck—but at least it’s
a decently statted creature.
Maze’s End is my personal favorite of these
in an Archelos deck—it comes in untapped
and can find you an untapped gate immediately,
and can be paired nicely with extra land play
effects.
And that’s not even the strongest way to
use Maze’s End in an Archelos deck.
I recently posted a video to my Patreon discussing
what ended up being my highest-effort deck,
and you can stick around to the end of this
video for a preview of that.
On some level, these adventures are cool simply
because I enjoy them—I enjoy a good puzzle,
I enjoy putting myself in somebody else’s
brain and asking why they decided to run a
particular card.
In theory EDHRec has an archetypes feature
that gives breakdowns on different deck types,
but it’s not very good—wow, you’re telling
me there are Francisco-Malcolm decks that
involve pirates, treasure, and sacrificing?
That’s crazy I never would have guessed.
So, in absence of a feature like this, I enjoy
the challenge of snooping around and figuring
things out.
However, this is also the part of the video
where I tell you that this goofy little thing
I like to do while using EDHRec is actually
fantastic exercise that will prevent all sorts
of mistakes down the line.
One of the biggest pitfalls I’ve seen EDHRec
users fall into is where they add cards that
look good without thinking about what deck
those cards belong in or how many of a single
card type belong in a deck.
This results in decks which have some amount
of synergy in theory, but which in practice
feel disjointed and clunky, containing a frankenstein-like
mishmash of components from various decks.
For this reason, I’d advocate spending an
extra moment trying to parse what specific
types of deck are actually being built with
the different cards.
Even just keeping in mind that there are different
decks doing different things within a given
commander will likely be a great help to newer
players.
EDHREC is a good tool, but it’s not one
you can go on autopilot with.
To echo the conclusion of the EDHRec effect,
you should try to keep in mind where the cards
you’re looking at are coming from, and that,
no matter how snappy the UI is, the stuff
you’re seeing isn’t magical, it’s just
data slurry.
With that said, thanks for watching, and here’s
a preview of a bonus video I made about the
Archelos deck I ended up building.